I KNEW I WAS TELLING THE TRUTH
AND I THINK THE COUNTRY KNEW I
WAS TELLING THE TRUTH.
I'M A BIG BELIEVER IN THE TRUTH.
>> Laura: YOU SHOULD HIDE
BEHIND THOSE BLUE CURTAINS.
CORAL WOODS -- BOROWITZ REPORT
AND THE DOJ HANDLING OF THE
TRUMP RUSSIA PROBE BUT STILL TO
JUDGE THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
QUITE PARTIALLY, HERE TO RESPOND
A BOMBSHELL -- RUDY GIULIANI,
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR.
WE DID NOT KNOW BOROWITZ WAS
BLOCKING OUT A SEPARATE REPORT.
JUST ON CALL ME LIKE THE BIG
BOOK LAUNCH SO MAYBE HE CAN DO
ANOTHER BOOK TOUR COMING OUT
TOMORROW.
WELL, I DON'T WANT TO OVERSELL
BECAUSE I JUST THINK I KNOW
BOROWITZ, NOT PERSONALLY BUT
ASSISTANT U.S. ATTORNEY AND A
GOOD ONE AND I HIRED JIM COMEY
SO I KNOW JIM COMEY.
>> Laura: SO YOU ARE
RESPONSIBLE.
>> THE PRESIDENT ALWAYS REMINDS
ME I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR
JIM COMEY.
BUT THE REALITY IS COMEY'S
CONDUCT WAS OUTRAGEOUS FOR A
PROSECUTOR IN ANY DECENT
PROSECUTOR, STARTING WITH A
COMPLETELY FIXED HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
THAT WAS A SELLOUT, A FIX FROM
DAY 1, A DISGRACE.
AND I DON'T THINK JAY HOOVER
EVER DID THAT.
I THINK IF YOU TAKE US THROUGH
THE STEELE DOSSIER, STEEL DEBT
AFFIDAVITS, AND STEELE DOSSIER
WAS VALIDATED AND PUTTING HIS NM
WAS VALIDATED AND PUTTING HIS NE
UNDER OATH AND STRAIGHT UP
PERJURER.
>> Laura: THE FISA COURT --
>> HE HAS BEEN A MUCH JAIL FOR
MUCH LESS THAN THAT.
>> Laura: IT DOES NOT REVEAL
DOSSIER FUNDED BY THE
PRESIDENT'S OPPONENT, MATERIAL
FACT.
>> I WAS THERE FOR THE BEGINNING
OF THE FISA COURT.
AND ONE OF THE FIRST.
AND THAT IS A SACRED DUTY
BECAUSE NOBODY GETS TO RESPOND.
I DID HUNDREDS OF AFFIDAVITS FOR
REGULAR WIRETAPS, MAFIA PEOPLE.
SOMEONE CHALLENGED THOSE
EVENTUALLY IN COURT, BUT WHEN I
DID A PFIZER AFFIDAVIT, IT WAS
MY RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE COURT.
THAT MAN LIED, STRAIGHT APPLIED.
NO WAY HE DIDN'T KNOW THE
STEELE DOSSIER WAS A BIG PHONY
PIECE OF JUNK.
YOU READ THE FIRST THREE PAGES
IF A PROFESSIONAL AND THIS IS
LIKE "NATIONAL ENQUIRER."
>> Laura: YOU WANTED IT TO BE
TRUE, RUDY.
SO THE PRESIDENT WOULD LEAK IT
OUT.
>> HE KNOWS IT'S NOT TRUE.
HE'S LIKE A 3-YEAR-OLD.
THAT IS PURE JAY HOOVER.
MAN I'VE GOT SOMETHING ON YOU.
>> Laura: IS AS A CRIME OR IS
IT A SERIES OF UNETHICAL ACTS?
HOW ABOUT A SIMPLE ONE THE
SIGNATURE ON THE FISA AFFIDAVIT
IS A CRIME.
>> Laura: HOW WAS IT A CRIME?
>> IT'S A CRIME BECAUSE FULL
STATEMENT UNDER OATH.
HE SIGNED UNDER PERJURY.
IT'S A FIVE YEAR STATUTE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE DID HE PUT IN
JAIL FOR SINGLE -- SHE MADE A
FULL STATEMENT.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE LEAK
OF THE DOCUMENT.
THE MEMO TO THE FILE, HIS OWN
FILE, HE HE WRITES MEMOS AND
THEN GIVES IT TO HIS PALS,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
>> THE LEAKING COULD BE MORE
UNETHICAL THAN ILLEGAL.
I THINK THERE WAS A CONSPIRACY,
HOWEVER, TO FRAME TRUMP.
I THINK THERE IS A CONSPIRACY TO
FRAME TRUMP.
>> Laura: THE PLAYERS WERE?
>> I CAN'T NAME THEM YET BECAUSE
THEY ARE UNIDENTIFIED BUT THIS
IS A COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
CONSPIRACY FEEDING INFORMATION
OF PAPADOPOULOS AND THEN
PAPADOPOULOS REGURGITATED TO
AUSTRALIA AMBASSADOR.
IT INVOLVES UKRAINE.
IT INVOLVES ITALY.
IT INVOLVES U.K., AUSTRALIA AT
THE BARE MINIMUM.
WHO COULD DO THAT FOR THE CIA?
COMEY COULDN'T ACTUALLY DO THAT.
COMEY COULD KNOW ABOUT IT, COMEY
COULD BE PART OF IT, COMEY COULD
BE A PLAYER IN IT BUT SOMEBODY
ELSE IS THE BRAINCHILD OF THIS.
COMEY PLAYED HIS PART AS A LIAR
TO THE COURT.
THERE IS NO CONFUSION ABOUT THE
CRIME.
THERE IS NOTHING CLEARER THEN
YOU ARE SWEARING UNDER PENALTIES
OF PERJURY, NAME, JAMES COMEY
PARAGRAPH SUCH AND SUCH, TOTAL
LIKE, GO TO JAIL.
>> Laura: HE ACTUALLY TWEETED
OUT LAST NIGHT.
YOU MIGHT HAVE MISSED THIS.
HE SAID HE WILL KEEP SPEAKING
OUT AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
HE SAID I'D HOLD A FORMER
COLLEAGUE I'M TIRED OF BEING A
TRUMP CRITIC.
HE RESPONDED
WORDS THAT APPLY TO ALL OF US,
WHERE YOU SEE WRONG, INEQUALITY
OR JUSTICE, SPEAK OUT BECAUSE
THIS IS YOUR COUNTRY.
HE IS RIGHT, KEEP SPEAKING OUT.
>> JAMES CARDINAL COMEY.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
WHAT A PHONY.
AND A TOTAL PHONY.
HE WILL HAVE PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES THREE OR FOUR
YEARS IN A FEDERAL PRISON
WRITING ABOUT ALL THIS.
THEN WE CAN READ ABOUT ALL THIS.
WE WILL HAVE TIME TO REFLECT.
>> Laura: EXPLAIN FURTHER.
>> NOT IF YOU PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL
FOR PERJURY.
>> Laura: BUT EXPLAIN FOR THE
VIEWERS, RUDY WHAT THE IG'S ROLE
IS.
HE CAN'T INDICT THE IG, THE IG
CANNOT INDICT.
HE CAN RECOMMEND VARIOUS
ACTIONS, BUT IT IS DIFFERENT.
EXPLAIN THAT VERY CLEARLY.
>> WHAT HE IS BASICALLY AN
INTERNAL MONITOR.
A PERSON WHO WORKS FOR THE
COMPANY TO TELL YOU HOW BAD YOUR
PEOPLE ARE IN A COMPANY BUT HE
CAN'T INDICT ANYBODY.